Now before we get started on the displacement part
of our landscape material,
I wanna talk really quick about how this works.
First off, in order to actually use this,
you are going to need to go
to the details panel of your material
and then under Nanite,
enable the enable tessellation checkmark box.
That's going to enable the displacement input
on your material.
Now under displacement in the details panel,
there's also a magnitude and a center.
What these two properties do is control the steepness
and kind of the center or the high and the low points
of your displacement.
So for example, if we were to take the center
and set this to a value of one,
what would end up happening
is we'd get something like this far image,
the entire displacement would be actually shifted up.
As we start to move the center down the,
from say a value of one to 0.5,
all the way down to 0.1,
we're actually gonna be shifting
or offsetting the displacement.
So here in the middle, we have a value of 0.5
and then here we have a value of one
and the 0.5 value looks and works pretty well
with this content.
The magnitude on the other hand,
this is gonna control the steepness of your displacement.
So if we have a low magnitude,
we'll have kind of high bumps,
kind of not really that big.
If we start to increase the magnitude really,
really, really big,
then we're gonna get some really, really large features.
We can also control our displacement through our material
by multiplying our end displacement
by some value to control over that.
So for our material,
what I have found throughout testing and building this
is that if we set the magnitude to 1.0
and leave the center at 0.5,
with the content, we will get really good results.
So let's go ahead and pop back over to our material now.
So right here, and then we get to click out of,
have nothing selected,
and then we're gonna come in here
and we're gonna look for our Nanite
and then here, enable tessellation.
And you can see here, I get the displacement input
and then right here under our displacement,
we're gonna set our magnitude to a value of one
and hit apply and then save.
And what we're gonna be doing inside of our material now
is the following.
We're going to basically take our dirt and our grass,
copy them.
We're gonna change the channel though to the blue channel
because that is where the displacement
is located inside of our mask.
And unlike our other ones, at the very end of our lerp,
before we go into our displacement,
we are gonna add a multiply and then a displacement amount
to allow us to control that displacement
inside of our material.
So let's pop back here to the editor now.
There we go.
So we'll just take this grass tile,
take all this code right up here,
control C, control V, move this down,
and then we're gonna rename this to D grass
for displacement grass,
and then D dirt for displacement dirt.
And we do need to change these textures.
So that's just a matter of coming in here
and selecting our grass
and then doing that again for this one,
coming in here and selecting our rock.
There we go.
And then we're gonna change this to the blue pen.
So right there and then right there like so.
And now we need to add our displacement controls.
So we're gonna hold down the one key and click,
and we're gonna right click on this,
convert to parameter and call this displacement amount.
And we're gonna give this a value of one.
And then to control this,
we're gonna hold down the M key.
We're gonna add a multiply,
and then we're going to have our displacement value
go into here,
and then we're gonna have this go into our multiply
like so.
And then last but not least,
we're gonna come right up to our displacement
and hit apply and save.
All right, fantastic.
So what we're gonna be doing next
is we're gonna be adding something called distance blending.
Now here is an example of distance blending in action.
So this is the exact same location.
And what it's using here on the left hand side
is a texture that maps the entire resolution
of the landscape to one texture.
And while this is very performant
and looks really good for the detail
and the far distance,
the detail that's very close to the camera
and the mid ground doesn't really look all that great.
It's actually very pixelated.
We can actually even see the individual texels
inside of that texture map,
and that's just not very good.
On the right hand side,
we have the exact same setup,
but we have this distance blending enabled.
And what distance blending allows us to do
is it allows us to basically take two different textures
and have one texture displayed close to the camera
and in the mid ground,
and then the other texture displayed
far off in the distance.
And we're actually gonna utilize this
for our landscape material
by creating the following material distance
blending function.
So what we're gonna do is we're gonna create a parameter
and we're gonna call that distance blend.
And then there is a material function
called distance blend.
We're gonna use that
and plug that into our distance blend reroute.
So let's go ahead and do that now.
So inside of our material,
we're gonna just come over here to some area
and I'm gonna hold down again,
the one key on the keyboard and click.
We're gonna click on this and go convert to parameter.
We're gonna call this distance blend range.
We're gonna give this a default value of say 1000.
And then what we're gonna do
is we're gonna look for our distance blend
by clicking into our graph.
And there we go, miss distance blend.
And then we're gonna take the output of this range
and plug that right here like so.
And then what we're gonna do
is we are going to click inside of here
and we're gonna look for a named
and we're gonna add a named reroute declaration node.
And we're gonna call that distance blend.
And then we're gonna plug this in like so.
So there we go.
Just have a look at this and we'll recap this.
What we did is we took that distance blend.
We made a parameter by holding down one
and left clicking to add the constant.
Then we right clicked on it, converted it to a parameter,
gave it a name of distance blend range
and a default value of 1000.
We then right clicked inside of our event graph
to look for our distance blend function.
And this allows us again to set that range.
We connected our output here
and then we added our named reroute declaration,
called it distance blend and plug these in like so.
All right, so we are going to need
to add some other commands here.
We are going to make a far tile grass and a far tile dirt.
And they're basically going to be exactly the same
as our dirt tile and our grass tile.
This is just gonna be for things in the difference.
And the main difference is that again,
we're gonna change the name,
but we're also gonna change the default value
to be something very, very small.
And this is gonna make the texture really large.
Let's go ahead and do that now.
So we're gonna come over here
and let's just grab these two nodes right here
and we can control C, control V
and we'll just move them out of the way.
And then what we're gonna call this
is we're just gonna put in the word, F-A-R underscore.
What I'm actually gonna do is I'm gonna take this farm
to copy it to my clipboard here.
And then we're just gonna do this.
We're gonna come here and we're gonna go paste.
So we get that far dirt tile.
Oops, need that E there.
And then we're gonna do the same thing for here,
grass tile.
So we're gonna call this far grass tile.
And then we're gonna do the same thing here.
So there we go.
We have now a far dirt tile
and our far grass tile with the company nodes.
And now what we're gonna do is we are going to grab,
basically set up our same slope like we have,
but instead of it being dirt tile or grass tile,
it's gonna be called far dirt or far grass.
And then what we're gonna do
is we're gonna take both of these.
We're gonna take our near and our far,
and we're gonna use a lerp node with our distance blend
to blend between them.
So again, let's go over to the editor
and let's go ahead and set this up
by first coming up here.
And we're gonna grab these two up here, right?
I'm gonna hit Control C, Control V.
We'll just move this up.
And we are going to have to get rid of these two
because we want the far dirt tile
and the far grass tile.
So let's just put the dirt down here
and the grass up here.
So we're gonna plug this in like so, far dirt.
And there is our, I should say far grass.
And we're gonna call this one BC underscore far grass
and BC underscore far dirt.
So there we go.
And then we're going to take this lerp
and I'm gonna hit Control C, Control V.
All right, and we're gonna take the output from this one
and plug that into here.
And then we're gonna take the output from this one
and plug it in like so.
And then we're gonna look for our named reroute
of our distance blend.
And we're gonna plug that in.
And once that is done,
we're going to plug this into our base color.
So now what we have here,
let me just kind of move this out of the way a little bit
is we have, again, let's go over this.
So we have our far grass tile and our far grass
and our far dirt tile and our far dirt.
And again, we're using the lerp based off of the slope.
So whatever we set here for the slope
will determine where these are set on,
or should say where these are shown on our landscape.
And then for our near grass and our near dirt,
what we're gonna do is the same thing.
We have BC grass, BC dirt,
we're using this linear interpolate
along with our slope to mix the two.
And finally, what we're gonna be doing
is we're gonna be taking these two
and then using our lerp again
to show one in the distance and one in the foreground.
And finally plug that in to our base color.
So what I want everybody to do now
is to repeat this process
and we will be back with creating a new level,
which will allow us to test some of this
before we go further.